now when you died what would you like to
leave behind well for Kate Green nothing
was as important as the happiness of her
two boys and her husband we she wrote a
bucket list for them and now a film has
been made about her hopes and wishes so
we can have a look guess the boys two
times after I've gone celebrate
birthdays big time and take lots of
pictures of my beautiful boys every
morning is the beginning of the rest of
your life this Mother's Day and we're
going to celebrate it every year because
it's a very special day for us
please keep using the phrase acres and
acres well we can speak now to John
singe Greene Kate's widow and author of
mums list and the books co-author Rachel
Murph you have an incredible it's a
desperately sad story tell us what
happened to Kate oh well it's the whole
family week absolutely hammered my
little boy got cancer 18 months old just
over Christmas period we would he was
diagnosed so Kate was pregnant at the
time so we had two babies then she gave
labour it was brought on early say Finn
arrives seven weeks early so like I said
two babies two different hospitals both
on sort of like machines to keep him go
in and then Reef's had like 70 or
general anesthetics that Emily's had
laser of operations to get out of him
and then just sort of put him back
together he's been left with a slight
disability to his leg which we we're
still treating and still doing stuff
with but he's an amazing little boy and
then he gets the all-clear and Kate
knocks it out and says I've got a lump
and that was you know the end of the
world so I think for me at that time and
you were told that you had 18 months
18 days well we told 18 months but only
actually was about 18 days again over
that Christmas period and we just come
back from Lapland and I you know I've
said in previous interviews that you
know there's not a doctor in the country
that would have stopped to go into
Lapland but she shouldn't have gone she
was you know barely breathing she was
couldn't walk you know she really
struggled but she didn't let it shade to
the boys for the boys she made it she
did
well and she my stick myself like do all
the activities that were put on by the
hotel so she did it for the kids you
know say it's really hard there's
nothing as probably as a marriage is
that but I was struck by the fact that
you were childhood sweethearts I mean
you know some of those relationships
that was actually well yeah back yeah we
met on rollerskates Robin cousins ledger
Center in Bristol I was the rink
supervisor I was a bit older than Kate
she was one of the girls that used to
come over and fall over over their mates
and I used to go and pick him up and and
then she sort of was she's always been
you know a bit feisty and I quite liked
that and and she sort of like said you
know it's her birthday and would I give
her a kiss which is all some of the
movie says it's very close to the mark
and she lifts she made look she made
list from when he first met her but when
she was dying it was these lists that
yeah Kate was one of those organised
ladies that sort of like gets everything
down you know and before sort of mobile
phones and stuff like that when we first
started dating I used to have notes in
my sock drawer like I love you and on
that when I got home from work there'll
be a little love you on the stairs or
somewhere like that you know as well as
all the shopping lists and all the other
things husbands yeah yes yeah absolutely
it's like you know see was wicked and
you know you can't ask for any more than
that when somebody's you know that you
know we were per side with each other to
be honest he and we travelled the world
wouldn't you know we did everything we
could to have a fun time together so we
did live life yeah right on the edge and
after she died the lists then took on
more significance yeah well when she
realized that she wasn't gonna make it
the list started off as just an
off-the-cuff comment Horst I was making
a cup of tea for her and she said would
I do something I said yeah yeah it was a
visit a beach when she said go to when
she was a child so it was very important
for her for me to share that with the
boys when she wasn't here and I was like
trying to stoop it back you know
behave yourself I'm trying to make you a
cup of tea I don't to be thinking about
losing me but then she rattled off you
know six or eight more like a machine
gun and I was like hang on you gonna
have to write them down and she did you
know and then I got
text messages because obviously now we
have maybe I'll say but I said it took a
while because I deleted quite a lot
because I was just wasn't prepared to
sort of part with thinking about losing
her so it was really tough in those done
and Rachel you're sitting along the
websites and you you you came along and
you've helped co-author the book and we
heard you know the film is also gonna be
released in three days time I suppose
the difficult is this it's a
heartbreaking story but but how to
convey that without it becoming too more
Koosh well when I was first asked to
call Finch and asked him if he was
interested in writing a book
I was nervous thinking you know how is
he gonna because it was only ten months
after Kate had died but cinge
answered the phones very cheerfully and
said oh what a wonderful idea and he was
just enthusiastic from the start and
just conveyed I think the message of
mums list right from that first phone
call because he said it'll be a great
tribute to Kate it'll be something for
the boys to keep when they're older
because they were so little they were
four and five yeah and and and also
hopefully we'll be able to raise the
money for charity I think we gonna get
bigger we didn't we really didn't and
we've managed to do all of those things
so it wasn't it absolutely wasn't as
just a cancer story I was afraid it was
gonna be painfully sad and honestly
we've we've laughed as much as we've
cried in writing the book to reddits
together you see that's what it is yeah
yeah well there you go
yeah one thing I was struggling that I
want to talk about the rights and wrongs
of a list because I think there are some
questions that people have about leaving
instructions almost on the grave but one
thing she was adamant about your late
wife was that you should remarry because
your boys needed a female presence yeah
I wish when you love somebody that much
it's a look yeah and you know that
you're not going to be there for all of
that life I think that was such a brave
thing for her to do as a woman to you
know let you go give you that got a jail
free card so I mean that was it that was
when it broke me to be honest I mean you
on anything message texts or whatever
it's you then realize that it's not
forever and I think Kate and myself both
believe that everybody should have a
happy ever after so that's why we did it
and I think from the book and the movie
and there's also a legacy program going
in we're looking at we're gonna help not
just hundreds of people not just
thousands but maybe hundreds of
thousands of people I've already
received messages from all over the
world thanking us for write in the book
I mean Rachel was fantastic she got
right inside my head and we spent hours
at the in London at Somerset House
sitting drinking coffee crying our eyes
out right in this work can I just talk
you about about the bucket list I mean a
a Gil Sunday Times writer announced on
Sunday that he had pretty advanced
cancer yeah and he quite explicitly said
I don't like bucket lists what he also
said he didn't like the language that
sometimes wrong with cancer a good
friend of mine has talked about this as
well as part of it you know that people
fight bravely against cancer they fight
some days you do have to but there is
almost this it is retained would become
a bit prescriptive that people then
expect to do so I didn't believe there
is like I think the the list came about
for us was it is the stuff that we plan
to do in our old age I mean there's
certainly the things on it you know
there for it's it's a rugby you know
Kate myself and my little boy reef
through all this treatment we're
watching the Six Nations on on TV and
that's one of the things on the bucket
list and we haven't done it yet so these
were ranged you know yeah so that's well
yeah I mean it but it's a prescriptive
one it's like you know I've got family
connections with Ireland so my dad's
proper English and we always have a
little bit on them on the set e about it
so you know it's something that I'm very
passionate about and the boys know that
we're going to do at some point if we
can afford to and then you know this is
what it's all about it's these it's what
you leave behind you know it's it's
people that you leave behind have got
pick up the pieces and get on with it
well I'm worried at all in this that
that she'd be betrayed this ought to
saintly this this perfect mum
a little but she was an amazing partner
she was an amazing mom she was an
amazing woman
and so I didn't want anyone to forget
that I loved her that much that you know
put you put your heart out there and you
know see what happens and I didn't
realize it was gonna get international I
think my English teacher would be
absolutely amazed
she'd be banging her head on the table
she always told me to stick to maths
because I was good at that but me and
Rachel we've just done in a remarkable
job in such a you know you know a tough
time really but there's none tougher
we're good mates now which is what's
really cool is the fact that we can you
know we can get together and you never
know there might be a sequel because
everybody wants to know what we've done
and how far we've got with a list so you
know dude well best of luck with it and
thank you for coming in the films up
Friday isn't it yep yeah well done thank
you very well thank you